[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joining you from the interval here
in san francisco where i'll be joined
by adam rogers our speaker tonight who
is going to be speaking about the
history
and future of color and perception and
culture
adam rogers was one of the very first
speakers we had here at the interval
way back in 2014 on his last book proof
which was really a kind of a similar
study
but on alcohol and culture but tonight
he's going to be talking about
both the science and history of color
and perception and how it has affected
civilization through
time welcome adam rogers
thank you xander it's really it's good
to be back uh
i want you to picture in your mind the
quintessential yellow
so not an object not a yellow thing
not a lemon but just yellow not orangey
not greenish yellow
okay you got it
now i don't know if this is it for you
this is how a lot of computers
code like yellow yellow and of course
it'll look different on every screen
because nobody calibrates the colors of
their screens and all screens are
different
all things being equal though and this
is a little bit weird
the yellow that you would pick as
perfect as quintessential if somebody
shined a light and gave you the controls
of the dials to pick perfect yellow is
probably very very close
to what another person would pick of
course all things are never equal we
measure color in a lot of ways
saturation brightness intensity
and those metrics vary from place to
place in time to time when we talk about
color let's try another warm up now i
want you to picture your perfect green
so not bluish not yellowish green
okay you got it now here's a weird thing
the green in your head right now is
almost certainly not
the green that someone else would think
of or would pick as their quintessential
green
people vary by a lot if you shine do
that thing where you shine the light in
their face and let them control the
dials it'll vary by as much as 60
nanometers if describing colors by their
wavelength
is your thing this is a good green
it's fine um it's a little yellow for me
actually
but an important question asked here i
think is why would this green not be
your perfect quintessential green
because the blue-green region of what
scientists call a color space
the entire multi-dimensional range of
colors
and variations and colors possible and
perceivable is a brutal
place it is a weirdish wild space now
partially
this is because of how your eyes and
brains work partially it's a function of
your personal experience of philosophy
of language of all the green lights
you've ever seen every traffic signal
every green field of england every
blade of grass every incredible hulk
color is physics color is culture and
you probably remember something
from elementary school called primary
colors the idea of those is that you
could have specific colors or
really and we'll talk more about this
too specific names
for colors that we agree upon and then
somehow try to understand
how those colors mix and come together
to form all the other colors because of
course color
is a continuous sort of curve or
waveform i guess
there's red yellow blue those are the
primary colors i was taught there's red
green blue those are the primary colors
your computer was taught
there's the muncell primary colors which
is a system of organizing color
this sort of unifies them all for
comparison's sake you can see how
different they are around the outside
is what isaac newton called the spectrum
the middle ring or the
artist's primaries and secondaries in
the inner ring are the additive colors
red green blue shine light put those
together they mix and form other colors
and the subtractive or reflective colors
that you'd find in a pigment
cyan magenta yellow and black cmyk
history is littered with the rubble of
attempts
to put colors into some kind of order to
make them behave
so that printers and painters and dyers
and weavers
and digital animators and artists of all
sorts
and people every day can use them can
take this mysterious but ubiquitous
feature of the universe
and turn it into something that we
change that we transform that transforms
us into
a technology so here's the hypothesis
when we talk about color we are actually
talking about three separate but related
and overlapping things
so first is color that happens without
us the tree falls in the forest it's
green even if we're not there
to see it tumble that's physics
chemistry the oscillation of
electromagnetic fields moving in a
direction
electromagnetic energy streaming from
the sun hitting earth's atmosphere
interacting hitting other surfaces and
particles light
1.21 sextillion photons hitting every
square meter of earth's
sunlit surface every second color is
something that we make
colored things by dent of our hands and
our effort and our cognitive abilities
roman purple egyptian blue move colors
that didn't
exist on earth or anywhere in the
universe i mean you know maybe
until human ingenuity makes use of all
that physics and chemistry to make them
happen
usually we call these things pigments
these are things that absorb some colors
of light and reflect others presenting a
color to our eyes
the image that you see there are jugs
full of quantum dots eventually those
are going to be part of led tvs
it's arguably one of the most advanced
way people make colors today
and third there's the color that our
eyes and brains manufacture from those
other two things
light all around us bounces off or
through or among
surfaces into our eyeballs where
hideously complicated biological sensors
transduce
photons into neuroelectrical signals
the image that you see now is uh ramona
kahal's hand-drawn map of a mammal's
retina
that comb-looking part up at the top are
the rods and cones
those are the photoreceptors the back of
the retina that
perceive light and color this is isaac
newton's original
spectrum um with colors added later he
didn't draw the colors in when he did it
famously in 1665 he goes on the run from
the plague and hides out at his mother's
house closes up the shutters with the
study he's working in pokes a hole in
the wall
sunlight comes in he lets that sunlight
go through a then relatively new optical
technology called the prism
and sees on the opposite wall color is
splayed out in a line
the eyes in the brain don't perceive the
same world of color that the universe
creates
what we think of as color is like all
the other senses
just an approximation so that first way
of looking at things this is
going to be familiar to you this is the
electromagnetic spectrum colored light
is in one sense just the teensiest part
of the physics that surround them
and this sort of makes sense why it's
that narrow band because we're using
meat sensors to perceive it longer
wavelengths uh would cook
those meat sensors and shorter
wavelengths would ionize them into
little balls of cancer
we humans call anything between about
380 nanometers and about 750 nanometers
we call that
stretch visible light those are colors
to us
you can see here that the peak spectra
of the three of them that most human
beings have in their eyes
people call those red green and blue or
short medium and long wavelengths but
you can see that the peaks aren't well
distributed
the tails overlap this is like
everything else in our meat suits an
evolutionary cluj
and in some humans one or two of them
doesn't work
somewhere humans have a whole other one
of them in there in between the green
and the blue
they are tetrachromats as opposed to
most of us
trichromats but the wavelengths it
responds to still fall inside the range
of what we
tend to call visible but look at this
birds
birds are tetrachromats they see colors
way down into the ultraviolet
and bees they're trichromatic like us
but they don't even bother with red
they're seeing the green and the blue
and then ultraviolet the natural world
positively glows to these other animals
we can't even begin to imagine and we
can begin to imagine but we don't see
what they see
they have other colors and look at this
show off this is a manish shrimp 12
photoreceptors
into the uvn near infrared jerks i mean
now except for the colors out on the
edges
most scientists don't actually think
that the mantis shrimp sees more colors
than humans it might not discriminate
among a zillion where we only do a
kajillion or something like that
it does do it faster the connections
between those receptors and what
what passes for a brain and a mantis
shrimp i'm not trying to be offensive
but you know
mantis shrimp but the point that i'm
trying to make here is that color is
quite literally in the eye of the
beholder what colors we see depend on
our
our biology the cone's sensitive to long
middle and short wavelengths i'll do
something called quantum catch they're
kind of adding up the number of photons
they're receiving at the energy levels
that they're sensitive to
this is a function of the proton
structures around them responding to
that energy
they aren't just sending red green and
blue signals back into the brain they're
combining their signals with each other
and with other kinds of neural
all kinds of neurons adjacent to them
and other kinds of cells that are
helping that process doing complicated
calculations within the eye
they're also doing overall number of
photons to calculate brightness or
intensity because the amount of light
and dark is part of the way we perceive
color and then that all reaches back you
can see in this diagram those two
circles at the top there are
eyeballs everything else is brain and
once you get into the brain what you
would love to say is like oh well
there's like a part for red and a part
for blue and a part for
green but no it's not like that at all
the parts of the visual cortex may or
may not map to specific colors
perceptions of colors
the neuroscience community's been
arguing about this for decades we
don't even really know completely why
we or anything else sees color at all
clearly it's some kind of information
clearly it's evolutionary evolutionarily
useful
part of the answer might be here if
you're local to long now you might
recognize the salt ponds
at the southern edge of the san
francisco bay those colors
come at least in large part from salt
loving extremophile microbes
called halo bacteria paleobacteria
aren't bacteria at all
they are members of the kingdom archaea
the oldest life on earth three or four
billion years old
obviously they do not see they don't
have eyes they are six microns long
they have color which means they have
pigments lots in fact
and they also know how to avoid blue
light and swim toward orange
which is weird because again no eyes so
halo halobacteria have a
protein called bacteriorhodopsin they're
using it
not to perceive light but as a proton
pump
basically they turn light into energy
but the thing is
that while the overall structure of the
protein is pretty close to ours
the individual amino acids that make up
that protein are different
it's like making the same spaceship with
different legos
so no one knows for sure if our color
vision
evolved from their color vision or if
color vision is so evolutionarily
valuable that that evolution just comes
up with it
again and again and over time the same
approach with different structures
nobody knows it's good for something and
we humans keep making our own colors to
feed our appetite for it
this is uh blombos cave it's on the
coast of south africa
it's been the location of a bunch of
really exciting archaeological finds
over the years
some of the first ornamental beads one
of the first drawings that human beings
ever made
between 10 and 20 meters down about a
hundred thousand years old the
archaeologists who worked that cave
found something
remarkable these are abalone shells and
the one on the right you can see a
little rock
down at the bottom and it's sort of
molded to the shape of the inner surface
than the nacreous substance on the
inside of the shell and you'll see also
some reddish color there that's ochre
and iron oxide these are tools for
grinding that ochre down for mixing it
with
they found samples of what's called
trabecular bone like you'd find in the
spine it's sort of
fat and marrow and cartilage porous and
gooey these are tools to mix all that
together and make
a pigment to turn ochre into a paint
it's the oldest known example
of human beings taking a natural
material and turning into colored stuff
they can use
the archaeologists who found them led by
a researcher named christopher
henschelwood
called these tool kits blombos was a
workshop
for making color technology but by the
time you have people painting
for example the insides of the caves at
lisco in the south of france tens of
thousands of years after what was going
on blombos
you have a pretty wide palette now this
isn't obviously enough of a gamut
to depict the entire natural world but
there's a lot of color there you've got
the ochres there's some coppery stuff
for green
the blacks are magnesium and carbon like
soot that's easy because you've got
fires
and sometimes you'll have something
almost always calcium carbonate based
for white and it's enough to make some
really striking image like these these
are from
the simulated lisco cave that the french
built just outside the real cave but you
can also ask
could the people who painted it also
have had other pigments
and the answer is yes maybe they had a
blue made from flowers or something
we know because they were humans that
they saw color like we do
we don't know if they made colors like
we do i mentioned the color white a
second ago
people actually argue about whether
white is a color or not an achromatic
something without color one eminent
color scientist called it this though
the mother of all
hues to some extent the history of the
way human beings have interacted with
color has been
a steady or punctuated progress of
having more and more pigments
and more and more ways of making things
have colors
but throughout all that time one of the
most steadfast principles you have to
have
something to make white something to be
a substrate that you can put other
colors against
something that when you mix it can
either make those colored things
lighter or give them more opacity or
make them brighter
so that essentially has been having to
have a white pigment
it's white is one of the bases of the
axis that you can measure
colors and brightness by it's been
omnipresent in
coloring roman buildings in the same era
that it was making ceramic and the tang
dynasty was also
became the basis for makeup that women
there would wear all the way up through
those famous pictures of queen elizabeth
with the sort of white cake
on her face that was all white people
really vibe on white stuff though
calcium carbonates include things like
lime and also kaolin which is the
mineral that makes ceramics and fine
porcelain possible
people try to make white pigments out of
all kinds of stuff in fact partially
that's because you need it to mix with
other pigments to lighten them and
brighten them and make them more opaque
but white's actually tricky because
where most pigments as i said
absorb some wavelengths and reflect
others white has to reflect pretty much
all of them but not
back the way they came because that
would be a mirror basically why it is
organized disorganization
refracts every wavelength every which
way for something to be white the
particles inside it have to scatter all
wavelengths equally and efficiently
water droplets suspended in air are very
good at this that's clouds uh protein
and fat suspended in water is very good
at this that's
milk for most of human history though
the big white was this
lead white it was a component of makeup
it was a component
of house paints was a thing that artists
use of course lead white was also scary
because it was hugely toxic and everyone
knew they knew since ancient rome how
toxic this stuff was
so much so because there was so much use
of it in the 19th century for industrial
uses and for paint because everybody
wanted their world to have nice colors
that the hazards of it had been become
the incentive to invent the entire field
of occupational safety
it was a mess which means the world was
open to a replacement
in the late 1800s an engineer named
august rossi
came from italy to new york and he made
kind of a business out of understanding
titaniferous ores
especially because people were trying to
mine iron out of the adirondacks
and make steel and that was like 25
percent titaniferous so
at that point most people thought that
the way you would make good steel out of
something like that was to take the
titanium out
but in 1908 rossi noticed that the
chemical process he was using a purified
titanium produced as one of its
intermediate steps a fine brilliant
white powder
he mixed it with salad oil and famously
brushed it across a piece of paper
this was a big moment rossi knew about
the dangers of lead
and he understood the hegemony of
national lead conglomerate that was
selling the stuff in paint
so he and his partner added a new
business line titanium dioxide pigment
it's the basis for all kinds of paints
and coatings it has a huge refractive
index it's opaque and it's bright you
find it even coatings and paints of
other colors it's the
it's the main ingredient in a lot of
those paints you also find it in
coatings of pills
some kinds of paper almost every
cosmetic in your medicine cabinet
sometimes in the white sugar powder on
supermarket powdered donuts because it's
relatively inert
used to be an oreo filling it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
internationally
drives a huge amount of business the
bright colors of modern art of the
industrial age
of streamlined madeiran that's this this
stuff and it's it really
it's everywhere even today sprinkles and
sudafed and
toothpaste this was all part of what one
historian has called a chromatic
revolution
in order to make products seem new and
modern they
took on new colors and uh that started a
kind of um
an interrelationship a dynamic where new
technologies would create new colors and
those new colors would inspire people to
create new technologies back and forth
even though there's some kind of crass
capitalism involved there
the the transition
in a you know really weird but i think
real way of uh
of dorothy walking from kansas into oz
of a world that goes from being not
black and white or sepia tone because of
course that's just the way people
now will think about it because we're
influenced by the way the movies looked
but
but colors that were more likely to fade
and that were more likely to be earth
tones
into something vivid and vibrant that we
think of as the
as the 20th century and now the 21st it
was titanium dioxide
really that was one of the things that
made that possible what
didn't exactly change though and what's
still kind of unclear is how we talk
about those colors this is changing
direction a little bit but
i want to ask you another question do
you see the color blue in this painting
this is the painting athena appearing to
odysseus to reveal the island of ithaca
by giuseppe battani it's a depiction of
a scene from homer's odyssey
those stories or rather one specific
read of those stories sparked a
tremendous controversy
that an increasingly colorful world only
made worse does everyone see the same
colors if they don't have names for them
or
read that differently what do you call
the colors between the ones you know the
names of
and what does that say about you and
your culture and about how the brain
works because
color is a really good way to understand
linguistics
which makes it a really good way to try
to understand cognition
in 1858 uh 10 years before this guy
became prime minister of england
he wrote a book called studies on homer
in the homeric age he pointed out that
homer never used a word that meant blue
or green
in the original sure the sea might be
wine dark
and dawn might be rosy fingered but like
what does that even mean
gladstone had a hypothesis the ancient
greeks
he said didn't see color like we do they
didn't say blue because they couldn't
see blue
that's nonsense of course they were
humans they had human eyeballs and
brains they
didn't lack the blue photoreceptor or
have different eyes that function
differently than ours
and you know maybe the ocean wasn't blue
maybe it was green or
black but most translators today agree
that the greeks were using color words
just differently those were colors that
meant something to them that had what
scientists call salience remember those
color orders that i showed you
plato's version of that went from white
to black and one of the primaries that
he used
was translated roughly to like sparkling
or brilliant that was a specular
illumination that specular
look was something that they valued so
that may be what the wine dark sea was
all about
um still though you know the idea that
some people you know
other kinds of people didn't see color
as well as like nominally civilized
colonialists did that was a pretty
sticky
idea so grant allen thought that he
would test it out
uh alan was actually one of the
inventors of both science fiction and
detective fiction
um but alan tried a cool experiment he
sent letters to as he said missionaries
government officials and other persons
working among the most uncivilized races
not above a bit of casual racism was our
grant
he sent those all over the world asking
those people to
ask the locals a bunch of questions and
the answer at the end basically was
yeah they all see the same colors they
don't all have the same names and
sometimes they don't have
some names for colors at all but if you
teach people the name in a different
language they pick that right up
people were seeing the same colors they
just didn't call them the same thing it
had something more to do with culture
than with biology
this was all anecdotal of course what
all this eventually led up to
in the 20th century was a mutation idea
into what's
now called linguistic relativism
sometimes this is called the superior
warf hypothesis
after a harvard linguist named edward
sapir and an autodidactic fire
investigator
self-taught linguist named benjamin
wharf and the most simplistic version of
the idea
even defining this is controversial but
just work with me is that
the things that you have words for in
your head are a limit on what you can
actually think of and about
language is thought like i said color is
a very good tool for thinking about
language so you can test this
or you can try in the 1960s two
linguists
brent berlin and paul kay had noticed in
their field work that some languages had
fewer basic color words
things like yellow and green like i
asked you to imagine up at the top that
didn't mean anything other than a color
than other languages did some languages
had fewer than others why
they decided to do a more rigorous
version of what alan had tried to do
with his letters
what berlin and k tried to do was ask
people basically which colors are which
what they're called which ones are
subcategories
what names do you have and so on and the
crazy thing is
they found a pattern they found that all
languages
develop color terms in a specific order
they said
first they start with white and black
then they'll include a red
then you get either a green or a yellow
then you get both
then you get blue and so on it turned
out to be pretty wrong
under fire for potentially some racial
assumptions and also because they
talked to people who were bilingual so
the languages would be overlapping and a
bunch of other things
they tried it again they went big they
went not to bilingual speakers in the
california bay area but to informants
around the world dozens of different
languages and places
and they found that what was going on
was much more complicated and mannered
that languages tended to
separate their color spaces into light
colors and dark colors and then develop
more words as needed
from there what we're talking about here
is something called categorical
perceptions the ability to distinguish
among
stuff and name that stuff so having
words for things really does matter
this is just a small example but russian
speakers have two basic color terms for
blue
they have a light blue and a dark blue i
won't try to pronounce those because my
russians i don't have any russian
um so whereas we just have blue they
have two
if you show people
those colors and then one of the other
ones so a triangle test two of one color
one of the others
russian speakers are faster at telling
you whether the third one is the same or
different than the others
than english speakers are the hypothesis
there being the idea being that if you
have the words for it
then you can see it more quickly you can
think about it more quickly
what you'd really like though if you
wanted to try to separate cultural and
linguistic influences on color
perception from like innate biological
categorical perception of color
you would want something that could see
like a human but didn't have language
so i recommend one of these uh this one
is mine
from many many years ago so and you
can't have that specific one
but something like this and seriously no
for real this works you do what anna
franklin at the university of sussex did
you strap some four months olds
into car seats and make them look at
colors because babies if they see
something unfamiliar they look at it for
longer it's got the
basic tool in developmental psychology
and you can tell what categories they
distinguish between
and which ones they don't if something
they haven't seen before they look at it
longer if they've seen it before it's
already in a category
then they look for shorter anna franklin
tried this
and found at the end basically the
babies see red green
blue yellow and purple before language
these are the categories of color but
what are the categories for
what do they mean in 2017 a couple of
researchers ted gibson was an
information theorist at mit
and bevel conway who's a color vision
researcher at the nih and
sort of my grew in all of this they
tried the same kind of show the colors
came with speakers
um that the berlin and k folks had tried
with native speakers of english
spanish and chimane which is an
indigenous language in south america
this shows which modal terms or basic
color words the speakers of each
language used for man-cell chips it
shows that shimano had fewer words
fewer speakers had modal terms for those
colors than spanish or english did
but then they tried something new they
played a sort of guessing game
they would take the color chips and try
to see how long it took people
in each language to describe a given
[ __ ] to explain which one they meant to
a person they were talking to
and the idea was that if you had fewer
words to do this if it took
less time to do it that meant that the
color was somehow more information
efficient
in the language that you were speaking
so these are from the top to bottom
different languages english at the top
then spanish speakers then gemini
speakers
and right to left information efficiency
it doesn't really matter which specific
colors do which because you can see what
the overall divide is there you can see
that there's a division between
what someone who's an artist like conway
is would call warm colors
and cool colors so there's roughly the
same difficulty conveying the idea of
the same colors
but in both colors in the warm longer
wavelengths
are the ones that uh that are more
efficient
why are they more salient you can tell
as many evolutionary just cell stories
about that as you want but this is sort
of clear proof that at least they are
somehow okay so what's next that's how
we make colors and think about colors
now a little bit
but because of that relationship between
technologies for making colors and
thinking about them
this is all changing a couple of years
ago i went to a lab at mit
researchers named yang she and michael
foshee they work with a 3d printer to
try to
basically forge paintings not for
criminal reasons but
what they're trying to do is print
paintings
that look indistinguishable from the
originals no matter what color light you
look at them under now that's a big deal
the way the iron brain remap the colors
that we're seeing to account for the
color of the surface the thing that
we're looking at but also the color of
the
ambient illumination is a vast mystery
nobody really knows how the brain does
it and what they wanted to do
was create a printout essentially of an
image
that would look the same under the same
kinds of different lights as the
original
so to do it they kind of reached back
into the past they took a process called
half toning putting little dots of color
next to each other to make color
printing that's how color printing works
familiar if you're a fan of comic books
or magazines or
neo-impressionism but instead of
limiting themselves to cyan magenta
yellow and black the classic colors of
magazine publishing
they added a bunch a bunch of pigments
red green blue violet orange
even a titanium white of course they
used a machine learning algorithm
and told it to look at colors that it
saw in the world and figure out how they
changed in our different illumination
and then come up with print the same
colors that the originals
they were able to pull it off almost
completely that's an original on top and
then the copies are below basically
every scanned pixel of the original
gets a a three-dimensional um like
hyperspectral reflectance map
that the computer then recreates with
pigments and the 3d printer multiple
layers of 3d printer
now there's some kind of color physics
going on there that figures out how
light interacts with surfaces
but nobody knows what that physics is
she and foshee don't know they left to
the machine algorithm
so they don't know how it works either
the computer is able to make fake colors
that nobody else knows how to make
somehow and nobody has yet asked the
computer
one of the things that the color
scientists that i talked to
were most excited about uh were the
possibilities less of like
high resolution screens and more of
wider gamuts
so the color gamut is what colors are
able to be shown by a screen
and the idea isn't that you'd be able to
show colors that people
can't see but to capture more colors
that they do see out in the world so
right now if you have a
screen with a to narrow a gamut and you
try to show a sunset
let's say you won't it'll it'll it'll
like cover up the colors that it can't
depict so everything will just look like
the same yellow instead of a bunch of
yellows and golds let's say
so a color gamut a wider color gamut as
part of what
new and oncoming standards in
high definition tvs and digital
televisions will have
but they were actually more excited
about high dynamic range
dynamic range is a different axis in
color space it's the light to dark axis
not the not the colors the actual hues
and if you can increase that axis if you
can make the dark super dark
and the bright super bright you can show
more
colors you can expand the gamut but also
some people think that you can even get
more um like emotional range there's a
researcher at dolby who studies
neuroscience as well as how to make
better screens
and she says that if you have really
really super high dynamic range and you
like
look at fire for example that your your
skin will respond as if you're seeing
heat
um pixar animators use uh the
six primary color laser projectors of
dolby high definition
digital cinema and the ultra high
dynamic range ramp from
bright bright white to black black black
and they're doing experiments with
inducing after images
using really bright colors to induce the
after image that's the complement of a
color
so that you'll see colors that aren't
really there
uh more colors and colored things are
still coming
every time people learn new color
science they use to make new color
technology
like uh these are all samples for
possible paints for cars
and uh way you do this is um you include
in the paint
mica little flakes like corn flakes and
they reflect light in different
directions
and different amounts of light in
different ways so you get the sort of
when you move around the
car it's red over here and green over
there
but mica actually comes with a lot of
impurities
so they're they're trying to use
artificial synthetic
mica maybe vantablack nanoscale
nanostructure black that's the blackest
black ever known
um or maybe what you see here this is uh
work from the researchers jingu park
and ben rogers at harvard these are
structural colors they're not made from
traditional pigments at all
they're they're nanoscale structures
tuned beads of styrofoam
actually that reflect light
mechanistically rather than chemically
i don't know if you're if you're an
entomology fan but a lot of beetles have
really extraordinary
carapaces they're the armor that they
have someone that's really specular it
looks like metal
glowing um and there's one called the
cyphoculus i'm probably pronouncing that
wrong
that's ultra bright white uh brighter
even than titanium dioxide is and it
does that
um not because there's any white pigment
in it because the the way that
the nanoscale the way its armor is
structured and after that
i don't know because of course no color
is impossible
there's no missing shade of blue even if
the ones that we can see
are limited by our own biology and our
own neurology the colors that we can
make
are probably not thank you
you